il faudra que nous menions une grande
réflexion sur la façon dont l'europe et
l'afrique doivent apprendre à travailler
ensemble
c'est une grande affaire si l'afrique
échoué l'europe connaîtra un drame quand
on regardait les globes terrestres de
nos salles de classe en tout cas pour
les très vieux ceux qui sont pas pressés
on voit bien que le continent européen
le continent africain
son frère dans le destin la question des
infrastructures de l'afrique est
clairement posée la question de l'aide
que nous devons apporter à l'afrique qui
est une aide que nous apporterons à nous
mêmes parce que nos chefs d'entreprises
auraient bien besoin des marchés
fantastique que pourrait représenter
l'afrique
quand on voit l'argent qu'on ne verra
jamais d'ailleurs qu'on a dû investir en
grèce et qu'on voit ce qu'on pourrait
faire avec moitié moins pour développer
l'afrique et permettre aux populations
là bas de rester dans leur pays d'avoir
un travail d'avoir une formation la
question très clair d'un formidable plan
marshall pour l'afrique penser imaginer
financée notamment par nous les
européens est clairement posée sinon
vous ne pourrez pas gérer les problèmes
migratoires à l'horizon de la planète